in season 1 episode 6 of The Big Bang
Theory the Middle Earth Paradigm Penny
throws a Halloween party in her
apartment Leonard shows up as a hobbit
hoping to show Penny he can fit into her
circle of friends but thanks take a
disappointing turn when Penny's beefy
ex-boyfriend Kurt shows up decked out in
a physique-bearing fur loin cloth and
when Leonard manages to insult Kurt's
marginal intelligence the angered Muscle
Man hoists Leonard off his hairy hobbit
feet as Johnny Galecki says in author
Jessica radloff's The Big Bang Theory
the definitive inside story of the Epic
hit series the scene took him back to
his use he admitted him picking me up as
Leonard really affected me to the point
where I think I cried after he shot the
episode it really dug up some old school
yard stuff for me I had a way into
Leonard and really began to understand
him so while the scene may have been
intense for the actor it also opened a
window into the character Galecki would
play for over 270 more episodes of The
Big Bang Theory
[Music]